all right so this you have to see
um as if things couldn't get any worse
for Rudy Giuliani he has now been
completely exposed by some newly
released audio recordings in which he
just straight up calls Ukraine and says
hey here's what we need you to say about
investigating Joe Biden and this goes
back of course to Donald Trump's
supposedly perfect phone call with
Ukraine and the entire impeachment
Fiasco Rudy's house has been searched
Rudy's office has been searched Rudy
farted multiple times during that bogus
bogus voter fraud Hearing in Michigan or
who knows where that one was Rudy
represented the most pathetic failure of
a president in the modern political era
and now caught on audio recordings it
just won't stop this is new content and
Rudy is potentially in some really
serious trouble here so let's listen to
the first clip there's something notable
here there's an important detail which
is actually a theme of these clips which
we suspected before so see if you can
spot it on this first time through
he's going to investigate and dig up
the evidence that presently exists
and is there any other residents
about
involvement of the 2016 election
and then the body thing has to be run
out
I don't know if it's true or not I mean
I I see
I see him bragging about it on
television
and to me is a warrior
me as a lawyer
sounds like a bride did you notice that
Rudy keeps saying we need him to say we
are investigating Biden this is not Rudy
wanting Justice Done he doesn't actually
say we need the investigation to be done
he insists that they need the
investigation announced and we had a
sense that this was the case from what
we knew before remember our
understanding before we didn't have
recordings but our understanding before
was they were asking for the
announcement of an investigation they
didn't really care about the
investigation itself because they wanted
the propaganda value to say look Ukraine
has just announced an investigation
whether it took place or not it didn't
even really matter it wasn't about
proving Joe Biden did anything or Hunter
Biden did anything it was about claiming
they are doing an investigation period
Joe Biden is under investigation is what
they wanted from a propaganda
perspective and there's more of that
phraseology in this next segment let's
check it out and listen to the exact
same thing
and that these investigations
go wherever they have to go
gonna be run by honest people that would
clear the air uh really well so there it
is again
if he could make some statements at the
right time justice has no right time
Rudy come on but Rudy doesn't care about
Justice and Rudy doesn't care about
finding out what happened that's not
what this was about this was Rudy and
Trump deciding we want an announcement
that there's an investigation into Joe
Biden at a time that is politically
suitable meaning suitable for Trump in
trying to get himself reelected against
who he imagined would be his opponent
Joe Biden let's listen to the last bit
here and and here you actually get the
offer of the quid pro quo it's it's
stunning that it's all on tape guys we
have the recordings now here is the quid
pro quo offer all right I think it would
make it possible for me to come and make
it possible I think for me to talk to
the president
and see what I can do
about making sure that whatever
misunderstandings are put aside and
maybe even
I kind of think that this is this could
be a good thing for having a much
a much better relationship where we
really understand each other
so there's the closing of the circle on
the quid pro quo if you announce these
investigations into Joe Biden not even
if you do them if you announce the
investigations into Joe Biden then I can
talk to Trump and we can resolve all of
those misunderstandings this is Gangster
code this is Mafia code right this is
you never fully say it but you say hey
uh you know our problem
I think if you were able to cut me in as
a partner on this business which means
give me some money so I don't rip your
you know whatever off uh if if you could
make me a partner in this in this uh
Enterprise
I think I'd be able to go and talk to
you know who and we could really come to
an understanding about what's whoa what
what are you talking about that is the
language that Rudy is using here we
could resolve the misunderstanding by me
talking to Trump I'll talk to Trump and
it's all going to be resolved meaning I
will get the messages you want over to
Trump and we can deal with sanctions we
can get you the military aid whatever
you want our problems we're going to be
able to solve them if these
investigations are announced into Joe
Biden it's almost identical to I need
you to do us a favor though
I needed it from the perfect phone call
I need you to do us a favor though they
were working for that favor among
multiple angles and we now have the
latest bit of it which is Rudy on tape
asking for it when does it become
treason
for the personal lawyer to the president
of the United States then sitting
president to offer favors to other
countries in exchange for favorable
public announcements to help that
sitting president in his ongoing uh
re-election campaign at some point don't
we have to start using that term
stunning and disgusting stuff doesn't
look good for Rudy one of our sponsors
is four sigmatic the company best known
for their delicious mushroom coffee four
sigmatics mushroom coffee is organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies I've been drinking
four sigmatic coffee a lot lately it
actually doesn't taste anything like
mushrooms it just tastes like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash and they have
over twenty thousand five star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100 of your money back
because they stand behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try four sigmatic is giving my
audience up to 40 percent off and free
shipping when you go to four
sigmatic.com com slash Pacman the link
is right underneath this video